does your business pass the miss you
test so one of the things I've always
found helpful in thinking about projects
that I'm working on is do I miss it when
I'm not working on it and this relates
to my book because last week I wasn't
able to get a lot of writing done
because 50 cent commented on my video
and shared it in my day exploded on me
and so I wasn't able to write and and I
kind of miss it this week in my very
first video in this series i talked
about how much i hate writing but you
know I built up a team and I built up
momentum and I've been able to get help
with the areas that I don't like doing
and and I kind of miss it and that that
makes me know that I'm on the right
track and I'd encourage you guys to
think about the same thing do you miss
the projects that you're working on when
you go away and I think a lot of
entrepreneurs we can get stuck in a
routine stuck in a habit and we see good
growth in there plateaus and it's
because you don't really love what
you're doing anymore and often you can't
get that clarity until you go away until
you stop doing it and then see do I miss
it or not and I think that's why
vacations help a lot of entrepreneurs
when you go off to another city another
country i know when i leave i miss the
work that i do you know i miss the
youtube comments that are mosquitoes
everywhere it's raining but we're Stuart
still doing videos i missed the comment
i miss making videos i missed the
meetings I miss I miss my business you
know it's great for a couple days like
I'm itching to get back and you know a
lot of entrepreneurs to they'll go away
and they'll realize maybe I don't miss
my business right and that's that's a
that's a good thing to realize because
then something needs to change and that
might mean you selling the business
moving on to something else it may mean
you changing your day-to-day life
changing the activities that you're
doing but it's a good rule for business
is a good rule for life if you do not
miss it when you're not doing it then
you probably shouldn't keep doing it
find another way to stand go follow
something that you are passionate about
I'm going to make a quick video today
because this rain is insane my was
hoping to get to whole foods today too
right but I'm not sure that's gonna
happen thundershowers all day long but
I'm gonna get to your question so here
we go Bo Ryan ass hello i saw your video
on youtube of a book publishing process
and I enjoyed it and I've just finished
my book congrats man and I wanted to ask
how can I get an agent to read it and
are you an agent or book publishing so i
am not an agent i have an agent the
agent that i have for publishing is
Dupree Miller I definitely recommend
getting an agent oh I dropped it I was
going to show you the mosquito I'm going
to do this inside because I hate
mosquitoes I'm very allergic to
mosquitoes moving inside moving it
inside we were agent so yeah I'm a big
fan of getting an agent what happened
when i got my book deal was my agent
basically lined up a whole bunch of
means with publishers back to back to
back to back to back and we pitted them
one against the other and i was able to
get a significant increase in the offer
kind of like when you're selling your
home and you get an agent to kind of
line up multiple bids doesn't end up
happening for me in the book and I got a
great deal as a result I could have gone
the publishers myself I feel like I
would have gotten as good a deal and
maybe not ended up with the right
publisher you know do what you do what
you're good at and and don't worry about
the rest I have people who around your
team who can support you right so I've
been looking at how can I get an agent
and I would look up I would just start
looking at look up all the agents and
and get your deal in front of them reach
out to them find out how you can connect
through Twitter Linkedin just through
email I'd be looking at my connections
who do i know that i might be able to
get an introduction to somebody else who
works at an agency itching like crazy
super mosquitoes but i would definitely
recommend going down that route they
take a cut of whatever deal that they
bring in but in my opinion is totally
worth it they more than paid for
themselves and I'm big fan at least so
far next up tomorrow weeks your book
will be done in October how much of your
book is completed now is it all written
and you and you're just tweaking each
page with your team that's a great
question so there are three sections to
the book in section one is pretty much
done section two most of the content i
think is written in a I don't say poor
way just like kind of four
draft my first straps are usually pretty
good it's not just a spew it's usually
good I don't make many modifications but
I'll need to go back and edit it and
section 3 is it needs a lot of love
section 3 is the application of of my
theories so section 1 and 2 are the
ideas and then section 3 is how people
at different sizes and different
companies are applying it and so I have
to go do those interviews I have mostly
lined up I've already done two and i'm
going to the US and a couple weeks to
interview two more companies including
menlo which I know Tamara was somebody
that you were asking about and and then
it's turning that into content for the
book so how much am I done let's go with
sixty percent I got a lot of work to do
until we're finished next up blue
feature builder I checked out your
playlist pretty interesting variety you
have there ha my music choices are all
over the place too I think it's
referring to the believe playlist that I
have and I'm a big believer in starting
the day with music that makes you
excited it gets you going because music
is a great way to instantly change your
state and so I created a bleep playlist
that was selfish that's for me and it
was a private playlist for the longest
time and then people were saying hey
we'd love to see that too can you share
it and so I shared it and I think it's
great to have a mix of tastes in in
every area of life and the food that you
eat the music that you listen to in the
activities that you're willing to try
out even just trying it even just trying
it and if you never go back to it just
having a curiosity and a willingness to
explore I think really overflows into
the rest of your life I've itching like
crazy from these mosquitoes I think it
exposes you to new ideas and
opportunities and I think it really
helps my business to have a variety of
interests and tastes and so I encourage
it next up Dolores of brilliant news
well done following your flow skipping
the occasional schedule only add value
to the book hurry up I need to read it
already Thank You Dolores unfortunately
it is a process the book is coming
and the promise as soon as I will let
you guys know and the last question
Bassam um dad rights and peace and love
from Egypt peace and love from canada
two men ok that's it a short one I don't
think I'm going to get the whole foods
hopefully this rain will subside and I
can make a quick dash because i really
like the environment being with a work
out there um if you guys have questions
about writing the book my process
anything i've talked about in this video
leave it below in the comments and i
will make a video response in next
week's episode thank you guys for
watching thank you for your support
really means a lot I appreciate it
continue to believe and i'll see you
soon